jeder denkt sich sie sitzen ein bisschen
im Boot und badeln links und rechts aber
das ist leider nicht der
[Musik]
Fall herzlich willkommen beim
sportrapport dem sportpodcast des
österreichischen Bundesheers heute zu
Gast Frau Zugsführer Anna Lehi herzlich
willkommen zweifach Olympia Teilnehmerin
im Kajak einer und zweier tätig in ihrer
Sportart Olympia glaube ich immer im
Zweier gefahren bis jetzt aber auch
schon
in beiden Kategorien gut unterwegs
gewesen erklärre uns einmal den
Unterschied und den kanosport den
kakport prinzipiell also der Unterschied
zwischen dem kerg einer und dem kerg 2
ist natürlich sehr simpel im kerg 2
sitzt man zu zweit im Boot im Einzel m
wird's ein bisschen happiger sage jetzt
mal weil da muss man sich selber
stabilisieren da hat man selber sein
Rhythmus in dem man reinf finden muss
und dann ist man wirklich auf sich
selber gestellt also da hat man keinen
zweiten mit dem man sich absprechen muss
was sicher für positiv ist es gibt ja
die Einzelkämpfer die gerne alleine
seind dem Sport ich für mein Teil bin
gerne zu zweit ich vche seit 2013 mit
der Wick schwarz im Boot ich find es
einfach viel angenehmer wenn man was hey
da ist wer hinten die ja auch noch eine
gute Freundin von mir ist es macht
einfach Spaß sie weiter zu entwickeln zu
zweit wirklich an die Details zu feil
die Hundertstel nur irgendwie
herauszuholen im Boot und ja es es ist
einfach für mich wunderschöner
Sport er ist draußen was mir sehr
wichtig ist ich bin gerne in da in einer
Halle drin und ja ich bin einfach gerne
in der Natur und ja durch den kanosport
sieht man natürlich sehr viel mal ist in
der Welt unterwegs und auf verschiedenen
rinnstrecken und lernt unterschiedliche
Leute kennen aus verschiedenen Ländern
und es macht einfach sehr viel Spaß
dadurch eben dass me meine Eltern mein
Papa kan Sportler war bin ich quasi in
das ganze hineingerutscht und jetzt
meine kleine Schwester auch also es
liegt ein bisschen in der Familie der
Sport aber ja es ist ja sehr spezieller
und besonderer Sport und für dich auch
sehr erfolgreich in der Familie
natürlich auch erklär uns gleich auch
jetzt zu Beginn noch den Kanu Sprint das
ist ja das was du machst genau es gibt
ja Kanu ist der Oberbegriff da gibt das
verschiedene Bereiche wie eben das
Wildwasserfahren Kanu poollo Rafting
Kano Sprint das Besondere dran ist dass
man wie die Schwimmer in Bahnen fahren
bei uns sind es neun Bahnen bei den
Olympischen Spielen sind es nur acht und
die Sprintdistanzen sind 200 m und 500 m
olympisch aber sind nur die 500 m und ja
das Prinzip ist eigentlich relativ
einfach vom startweg wer es erste im
Ziel ist der hat gewonnen und ja es ist
äh Kraft
austauschportart wir trainieren zwischen
5 bis 6 Stunden am Tag weil es ist sehr
hoch lakttizieht sagen wir mal so im
Doppel brauchen wir für 500 m ca eine
Minute 40 das ist ca dann der Bereich wo
es wo zum wedur anfangt wo man dann weg
von der Schnelligkeit in die Ausdauer
ein muss es ist immer bisschen knifflig
es ist der innere Schweinehund den man
da quasi überwinden muss ja das andere
besondere ist dass das bot relativ
schmal ist das bedeutet du musst der
Stabilität sehr gut un der Kontrolle
haben was zu zweit bisschen nniffliger
ist weil D musst wirklich sehr gut
abgestimmt sein sehr synchron sein für
die Synchronität ist die wirklich
zuständig wie man sieht auf dem Bild
macht sie das super gut ja es sind sehr
viele Punkte die einfach perfektioniert
gehören im kanosport wie schon gesagt
Ausdauer Kraft Schnelligkeit und die
Balance in dem ganzen optimal zu halten
weil sonst fällt man im Wasen Sinne das
Wortes ins Wasser und das muss natürlich
äh auf jeden Fall verhindert werdenau
jetzt hört man in dem Bereich auch noch
vom Kajak Kanadier
also was ist da Unterschied beim
Kanadier
ihr fahrt ihr da mit doppelseitigem
Padel genau wir fahren mit einem Padel
und zwei
paddelflächen und sitzen im Boot die
Kanadier Fahrer die Knien im Boot und
die lenken durch ihr Kanadier Badel und
das kanader Badel hat nur unten eine
viel größere Fläche beim Kayak da lenkt
immer die vordere also ich habe da so
ein lenkstab vor zwischen meinen zwei
großen Zehen und hinten ist das Ruder
das eben das Boot nach links oder nach
rechts lenkt und die vordere im Boot die
lenkt immer das Boot der kanadierfahrer
der muss durch die Bewegung des Kanadier
badels des Boot lenken was viel viel
schwieriger ist und viel viel mehr
Balance in Anspruch nimmt und meiner
Meinung nach einfach zum Kajaksport zum
Sprint der Kanadier viel schwerer zum
erlernen ist das heißt es nicht möglich
dass du jetzt sagen würdest ich möchte
das jetzt dazu nehmen in mein Repertoire
also muss man sich wahrscheinlich
spezialisieren ja das ist also unmöglich
die haben ganz andere Muskelgruppen die
sie antrainieren müssen dadurch dass sie
knien brauchen sie viel stärkere Beine
was wir jetzt im kak wir verwenden
unsere Beine auch zum zum badeln z.B für
die Synchronität des schlageswert wird
die Beinarbeit verwendet und zum
Stabilisieren die kanadierfahrer die
haben natürlich extrem ausgeprägte Beine
was für mich dann bedeuten würde dass
sie sehr viel Jahre bräuchte um erstens
ein mal die Technik zu erlernen das
Lenken zu erlernen und die Muskulatur
für die Sportart
mehr anzueignen also es ist wieder
komplett was spezielles in eine andere
Richtung da würde man wahrscheinlich
auch dann den Unterschied beim Rudern
finden wenn du sagst eure Beine sind in
dem Sinne nicht
Antrieb steigernd im Einsatz sondern wie
du gesagt hast ausgleichend und lenkend
aber es jetzt nicht so dass dass das in
dem Sinne dann im Rennen selbst eine
ganz körpportart ist wie das Rudern oder
doch es es ist eine ganz körpersportart
weil man spürt zuerst in den Beinen das
Laktat okay weil die Beinmuskeln sind
doch eher die größeren Muskeln man
versucht wirklich das ein bisschen
aufzuteilen dass das Laktat nicht gleich
im Oberkörper verspürt wird sondern das
baut sie dann schön langsam auf es ist
schon ein ganzkörpersportart aber es ist
dann einfach für uns besser dadurch dass
eben die Boote auch so schmal sind also
man muss sie vorstellen wir können uns
nicht bewegen in den Booten da sitzt wir
wirklich komplett fix drin und die Beine
dürfen nicht zu ausgeprägt sein weil
sonst passen wir nicht ins Boot also die
müssen relativ schmal sein relativ dünn
sein aber trotzdem trainiert und
muskulär die Ruderer hingegen durch dass
sie eben auch mit Ruderern trainieren in
Ottensheim auf der regatastrecke die
haben extrem ausgepräckte Beine also ich
glaubt z.B nicht dass er ruderei in akak
hineinpassen würde ja und sich dort
wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht so wohl
fühlen würde genau war dann relativ F
und das Wasser schnell mal kosten würde
würdest Du sagen dass die stärksten im
einer auch automatisch die stärksten im
Zweier sind oder kommen dann noch
Komponenten wie du jetzt gesagt dass
Synchronität und Lenkung und sowas dazu
die dann im zweiah noch mal ausgeprägter
sind also ich würde sagen so und so es
gibt Länder die wirklich die zwei
stärksten im einer zusammensetzen es
gibt dann aber auch Länder die die
schauen von der Technik her welche zwei
Personen passen am besten zusammen ein
gutes Beispiel sind glaube ich und die
Wickel wir sind im
Einser jetzt nicht international gesehen
topbote aber wir sind einfach schon so
gut eingespielt und schon so so synchron
und technisch stabilisiert dass wir auf
einem zweier Niveau fahren wie
große Nationen also wir machen das
technisch weg was unsere Konkurrentinnen
sagen körperlich uns einfach überlegen
sind war das für euch auch immer von
Anfang an klar wer vorne sitzt wer
hinten sitzt wie die Aufgaben verteilt
sind oder habt sie das durchgespielt und
durchprobiert dadurch dass die Wicki ein
bisschen älter ist wie und i ist 2013
mit ihr ins Boot gestiegen bin und sie
vorher zwei andere Partnerinnen gehabt
hat und immer hinten gesessen ist war es
relativ klar dass sie einfach hinten die
größere Erfahrung mitbringt und die
vordere das ist ca ähnlich zum
Einzelfahren also ich bin vorher bis 23
nur im Kayak einer gefahren da ist man
quasi eben im Einzel mit wem hinten dann
im Zweier ich habe mir nicht wirklich so
auf zu viel einstellen müssen dann und
ja sie hat eigentlich am Anfang die
schwierigere Arbeit gehabt dass sie sie
quasi komplett auf mir einstellt
mittlerweile im Training dann wir schon
hin und her wechseln also momentan nicht
da die wir schwanger ist aber ich bin
schon auch hinten gesessen bei bei
Rennen bei verschiedenen
österreichischen nationalen Rennen durch
manur wirklich immer hin und her
wechseln und ein bisschen ausprobieren
es ist glaube ich auch sehr wichtig dass
man sie Sportler weiterentwickelt und
andere Sachen ausprobiert und man schaut
hey was macht eigentlich meine Partnerin
meine Kollegin da hinten sie kann danach
schauen hey wie ist es eigentlich wie du
sie mir Nachschlagen das ist glaube
einfach wichtig für für Sportler selber
dass der Horizont ein bisschen da
erweitert wird und auch immer neue
gesetzt werden jetzt hast Du
angesprochen Wick ist derzeit im Prozess
der Baby Pause du fährst deswegen auch
mit deiner Schwester Adriana wie macht
sie das wer sitzt vorne wer sitzt hinten
bei mir sitzt die Adriana vorne dürch
die Adriana ist erst 17 Jahre alt und
wie gesagt wie bei mir auch fehlt
einfach die Erfahrung hinten und sie
kann sie vorne einfach auf sich selber
konzentrieren und ich bin dann hinten
dafür zuständig dass ich sie so gut wie
möglich unterstütze und im Wasen sin des
Wortes ins Ziel schiebe und ja wir sind
jetzt die Europameisterschaften in
München gemeinsam gefahren und ja das
hat wirklich super gemeistert und es war
mir lustig mit der kleinenchwester im
Bot zu sitzen was das nächste Jahr
bringt wird sich rausstellen weil die
Wicke wir wieder zurück ins Boot schauen
wir mal ich lasse einfach auf mich
zukommen und bin gespannt wer
entscheidet sowas ist das eine
verbansentscheidungs entscheiden dass
die Athletinnen selbst wer mit wem
fahren möchte oder wie funktioniert das
natürlich ist der verbandsentscheidung
die Athleten selber müssen die
Leistungen im einer erbringen aber es
ist schon klar für den Verband dass wir
einfach eingespielter zweier sind und es
dann doch nahe liegend wäre dass der
zweier dann wieder startet aber
natürlich müs müssen die Zeiten passen
die Leistungen passen und an diese
ganzen Faktoren muss ich dann der
Verband orientieren weil im Endeffekt
wird dann einfach der schnellere zweier
international weggeschickt um natürlich
dort Limits etc zu erbringen für die
ganz großen Wettkämpfe Olympische Spiele
was zweimal schonau sch dabei in Rio de
Janeiro und eben in Tokyo letztes Jahr
wie war das so für dich die Olympischen
Spiele im zweiah zu erleben ja spannend
Olympische Spiele sind wieder komplett
anderes Erlebnis ein komplett anderes
Rennen die Atmosphäre ist eine ganz
besondere in Rio bin ja mit dervon
Schuring im Doppel gesessen durch
gewisse Umstände haben wir dann 10 Tage
vor die Spieler quasi den zweier
umändern müssen und ich hab dann andere
Partnerin gehabt im zweierah und Tokio
bin ich dann mit der wickim zwe Gefahren
Tokyo war eben durch Corona sehr
speziell interessant
und komplett anders also die ganze
Atmosphäre von den Spielen ist da
bisschen verloren gegangen was ein
bisschen traurig war es waren keine
Zuschauer dort also ist wirklich die 500
m runtergefahren in purer SLE wir haben
nur die Trainer vom Ufer aus schreien
hören und ja es war so ein bisschen wie
ein Trainingswettkampf hat sich das
angefühlt weil eben das ganze Publikum
ist weggefallen das war das war schon
relativ traurig finde es ist schon
abgegangen im Rennen gerade bei
Olympischen Spielen ihr seid dort
trotzdem persönliche Bestzeit gefahren
am Ende stand der ZTE Platz du sagst
jetzt natürlich ja ich habe hier stehen
in Anführungszeichen nur der 12 Platz
habt sie euch da mehr gewünscht mehr
erhofft mit einer Bestzeit ja also wir
sind wirklich 1394 wenn ich mir jetzt
nicht deusche s wir gefahren das war die
Zeit die wir ein angepeilt hätten vom
Training her und wir haben gewusst wenn
wir diese Zeit fahren dann ist top fix
aber dieses Jahr war bei den Olympischen
Spielen Doppelbesetzung das bedeutet es
dürfen zwei BR staten pro Land des war
dann der Faktor der uns dann quasi aus
dem Finale rausgehört hat weil so Länder
eben wie Ungarn wei Russland Deutschland
das war dann eher für uns unmöglich dass
man die schlagen wenn die nur zweites
bot an den Start stehen wir waren ein
bisschen enttäuscht aber auf der anderen
Seite auch sehr froh darüber dass wir
einfach unser Ergebnis abrufen haben
können in dem Moment also wir haben
alles gegeben wir haben das Optimum für
uns rausgeholt die Endplatzierung war
ein bisschen enttäuschend aber wir
selber haben uns in die Augen schauen
können und wir waren happy mit mit
unserer eigenen Leistung und es kommen
ja die nächsten Spiele Paris steht ja
wirklich schon vor der Tür ich nehme mal
an dass ist etwas was du anvisierst auch
wenn Wiki wieder zurückkommen möchte ins
Boot was nimmt man sich da vor wenn man
jetzt schon so viele Jahre gemeinsam
erfolgreich gefahren ist wie geht man
das so eine Zielsetzung für Olympische
Spiele an ja das Ziel das wird sie nicht
ändern auf jeden Fall ins Finale fahren
und was uns sicher zugute kommt ist dass
wir routiniert sind dass wir einfach
schon sehr gut zusammenpassen
und eben i2 Olymp Spiel hinter mir hab
wir vier olympische Spieler hinter sich
hat da ist quasi die Nervosität von den
Olympischen Spielen die einfach ganz
anders ist wie bei anderen Wettkämpfen F
vielleicht dann auch weg die vielleicht
ja anderen Ländern Länder Schau haben
und ja schauen wir mal im August ist es
ist die Quali die Top a Boote glaube ich
qualifizieren sich für die Olympischen
Spieler es wird sicher schwer werden Top
8 bei der WM zu werden aber es ist jetzt
nicht unmachbar also ich glaub
wird eher ein schwierigeres Jahr mal
schauen wie es wie es funktioniert aber
wir haben da nur eine Qual Möglichkeit
eben 2024 da qualifiziert sich noch ein
europäisches Boot und meiner Meinung
nach müssten wir dann des anbeilen weil
Heer ist vielleicht die Zeit zu kurz um
wirklich gleich auf dem Niveau mitfahren
zu können das weiß man be euch dass der
qualiprozess fast schon so schwer ist
wie dann das Rennen selbst bei den
olympischen
Spiel einfach die Konkurrenz so groß ist
wird auf jeden Fall klappen davon bin
ich überzeugt wenn du die Möglichkeit
hättest mit deiner Schwester in einigen
Jahren bei Olympischen Spielen zu
starten würdest du das so ein Projekt
auch angehen wollen ja auf jeden Fall
also ich glaube dass Adriana mit 18 wird
sie also nächstes Jahr im Februar schon
relativ jung ist aber sie ist sehr
ausgeprägt für Alter das bedeutet sie
ist jetzt schon mittlerweile über an 70
hat sehr gute Werte die letzten drei
Monate in der Kraftkammer gehabt und die
jungen Sportler die sind immer sehr
unberechenbar muss ich sagen also das
passiert von einem Jahr auf dem auf das
andere das bum die auf einmal se eine
Leistungssteigerung haben deshalb ich
bin eher ruhig ich schau mal das als
erstens aber ich würde mich freuen wenn
ich in Los Angeles mit ihr an den Start
gehen kann also das wä vielleicht noch
ein Ziel wenn ich mich entscheiden würde
nach Paris noch weiter zu fahren ja auf
jeden Fall eine gute Motivation und wird
sicher im Hause le auch gut begrüßt
werden ja also der Papa wird sich sicher
sehr freuen wenn ich dann sagen würde ja
noch vier Jahre schauen wir mal es ist
natürlich leistungspasierend wenn die
Leistung nicht passt hat es auch wenig
Sinn dass man sagt ja wir machen jetzt
eine Olympische Spiele mit weil es es
ist schon wichtig dass die Leistung beim
Papa passt weil sonst macht alles keinen
Sinn was er natürlich logisch ist also
rein sportliche Perspektive auch darauf
genau jetzt weiß man dass eure
Trainingsjahre die ihr im Training
mitbringt wahnsinnig wertvoll sind und Z
jetzt natürlich die Jungen immer wieder
überraschen aber im rannen dann doch
manchmal ausschlaggebender ist was du
als routinierte Sportlerin mitbringst
ist das auch ein Trumpf in seinem rannen
ja man merkt dass die routinierten
Sportlerinnen die gehen das Rennen oft
ruhiger an weil die Jüngeren die starten
immer gleich raus und spüren dann noch
kurzer Zeit das Laktat es sind trotzdem
500 m das ist eher Mitteldistanz wir
sind nicht der komplette Sprint es ist
eine Minute 40 zum vergleichen ist es
z.B mit 800 m Leichtathletik wenn man
wenn man da jetzt einen Vergleich sucht
man sollte nicht komplett rausstarten
und schauen ja vielleicht schaffe ich es
ins Ziel vielleicht auch nicht man s
wirklich ein bisschen Taktik an den Tag
legen und das tut man einfach in einem
gewissen Alter man hat einfach die
Rennen dann Inus die Routine Inus was
natürlich dann den jüngeren
Sportlerinnen abgeht und die einfach
komplett rausstarten und dann schon
langsam dann einen Abfall haben wobei
die routinierten routinierteren
Sportlerinnen wirklich dann zum Schluss
klassisch gut ins Ziel kommen erinnerst
du dich an ein Randen wo du diesen
Fehler gemacht hast ja genau deswegen
sage ich das ich ich hatte schon einige
Rennen wo ich diesen Fehler gemacht habe
so mit 20 21 ich kann mir noch erinnern
als ich in die leistenklasse
aufgestiegen bin was eh super ist voll
Enthusiasmus ins Rennen rein es ist eh
gut dass man sie viel vornimmt aber es
ist auch gut dass man bisschen ein Gang
zurückschaltet und ein bisschen taktiert
bei uns und es ist mal schon ein paar
mal passiert ja jetzt läst es
durchgingen es ist auch ein bisschen
eine Gefühls Sporter man muss das Paddel
spüren das Wasser spüren wahrscheinlich
auch du machst immer wieder so
challenges wo du dieses Gefühl auch
anderen vermitteln möchtest und sie
wenigen Sekunden meistens dann ins
Wasser fallen warum ist das so wichtig
das weiterzugeben oder wie kann man das
überhaupt weitergeben an einen
unerfahrenen padler es ist halt schwer
sich vorzustellen wie wie kompliziert es
ist in SE einem Boot zu sitzen jeder
denkt sich sie sitzen ein bisschen im
BoD und badeln links und rechts aber das
ist leider nicht der Fall man muss ein
gutes Wassergefühl haben wie beim
Schwimmen also es hilft dir die ganze
Kraft nichts und die ganze ausd nichts
wenn du das Wasser nicht spürst das ist
bei uns das um und auf das Problem ist
wenn sich wer neues ins Boot reinsitzt
und noch nie vorher in dem Boot gesessen
ist dann kippt er gleich einmal weg und
ins Wasser rein zuerst muss man mal die
Stabilität finden und verstehen dass das
Wasser dafür da ist dass man sich
abstützt also das Wasser ist ja eine
Stütze wenn man das richtig hernimmt mit
dem Badel und wie beim Schwimmen wir tun
ja auch viel schwimmen im Winter beim
Kul schwimmen muss man den den Zug vorne
nehmen und sich zuerst abstützen und
dann den Zug machen genau das gleich
Prinzip wie beim wie beim Kajak fahen
und das muss man glaube ich erst einmal
verstehen dass das wirklich nicht nur
Kraft und ausdau und reinhauen ist
sondern es spielt eigentlich nur also
wichtig ist dass das Gefühl dabei ist
weil sonst wird's wird schwer ich sehe
ihr habt in Linz sehr gute
Schwimmtrainer du hast die zck
druckdynamik so nennen wir das immer im
Training gut verstanden sich am Wasser
vorhandeln du machst das dann eben im
paddle und den meisten gelingt das dann
nicht so gut wenn sie da deine
challenges machen nach wie viel Sekunden
liegen es dann meistens im Wasser genau
also die meisten muss ich wirklich sagen
wenn wir versuchen am Anfang zu
stabilisieren sie sitzen aber auch in
unserem Rennboot also wir sind dann
wirklich gemein und lassen sie dann
nicht in so breitere
wanderboote das erste mal die ersten
badelschläge Ausprobieren sie sitzen
dann wirklich in unseren schmalen
rennboten und wir versuchen dann hinten
selber zum Halten und zum Stabilisieren
dass wir wirklich ein mal probieren dass
ein paar Schläge machen in dem Moment wo
wir hinten auslassen liegt normalerweise
gich jeder es gibt Personen die selber
auch sportlich sind und eben ein gutes
Körpergefühl haben die schaffen es dann
wirklich so 10 bis 20 Sekunden im Boot
zu sitzen nicht zu badeln nur zu sitzen
aber die verstehen dann eben das was ich
vorher erklärt habe diese diese abstütze
Abstützung am Wasser und das das
funktioniert dann ganz gut aber noch 10
bis 20 Sekunden wenn die ersten
badelschläge ohne Halterung probiert
werden dann geht's wieder ins Wasser es
ist für uns sehr müant muss ich ehrlich
gestehen machen das recht gerne und ich
glaub das macht das Spaß für die anderen
dass ihr wirklich ein mal ausprobieren
wie wie schwer das eigentlich ist dass
man nur in dem Boot sitzt wie lange
dauert das bis man sowas dann wirklich
stabil kann und keine Ahnung 100 m
fahren kann
ohne Wasser zu fallen es ist schwer für
mir einzuschätzen weil ich mach das
seitdem ich 8 Jahre alt bin also das
muss man glaube wirklich als Kind
anfangen das ist wie radfahen für für
junge Sportler also die wickke hat
glaube ich mit neun oder 8 Jahren
angefangen meine Kleine Schwester mit
vier Jahren angefangen das ist was das
das hast dann einfach drinnen und wenn
du das einmal kannst ist es wirklich wie
Radfahren dann kannst du das immer in
einem gewissen Alter wird es dann halt
wirklich schwer da musst einfach auf die
breiteren Boote wechseln dass du das
wirklich auch genießen kannst am Wasser
zu sein und zu baddeln in einem Rennboot
wird's dann glaube ich eher unmöglich
werden machst du das auch dass du dann
irgendwie so Ausfahrten machst wo du mal
gemütlich einfach paddelst oder geht das
gar nicht als spitzenspadel also locker
schwimmen gehen z.B für mich ist eher
eine Qual als dass ich es genießen kann
weil ich halt nicht schnell bin und im
Training möchte ich schnell sein gibt's
das bei euch auch stim das ich glaube
bei uns gibt's auch lockere Einheiten
das sind dann eher die
Trainingseinheiten aber die werden
relativ kurz gehalten sagen wir mal so 8
km also wirklich sehr kurz für uns weil
für uns ist es einfach sehr unangenehm
wenn du so langsam badelst dass du
erstens mal die Stabilität hälst und das
Sitzen wird dann eine Qual also solange
am im Boot sitzen und wirklich mehr
stehen als wie und technische Übungen
machen wird das dann am Sitz Bein Höcker
wirklich unangenehm ich mach das auch
sehr ungern also so langsame ausfen mit
wem der der nicht gut badeln kann der
Wechsel eher zum Standard pedle das ist
dann eh okay weil dann kann ich ganz in
Ruhe badeln aber selber im Boot sitzen
und langsam fahren ist eher unangenehm
okay das wä dann meine meine verpool
Version
ausze und Arbeit für mich übernimmt das
ist dann bei euch das Standup du gesag
sagt du hast im Endeffekt das
den kanosport in der Familie mitbekommen
kannst du dir vorstellen dass Du nachher
all das was du gelernt hast auch
weitergibst dass du dem Sport so
erhalten bleibst in welcher Form auch
immer ich versuche jetzt momentan eben
da da mit sehr viel junge Sportler
gerade trainier
Ihnen auch so im Training ein bisschen
was mitzugeben ich versuche ein taktisch
was mitzugeben weil ich finde es sehr
wichtig und auch technisch was
mitzugeben
und ich merke einfach selber dass das
gut aufgenommen wird und das also das
macht mir schon sehr viel Freude vorher
war das eben nie der Fall weil wir haben
nie mit jüngeren Sportland trainiert wir
waren immer im Ausland und haben mit
anderen Sportlern aus anderen Ländern
trainiert da war das nicht der Fall dass
man sie da ausgetauscht haben ganz im
Gegenteil also da ist so ein ganz andere
Sachen gangen als wieder ein anderen
vorzutreiben und jetzt ist es heute
komplett neue Situation und das macht
mir schon sehr viel Spaß und ich was bin
mir noch nicht sicher ob wir in Zukunft
auch wirklich in die Richtung gehen will
beim kanosport aber nach dem Ende meiner
Karriere kann ich mir schon vorstellen
dass ich mal Boot nehmen und PA
rundenoten sein aber wirklich dann
hobbymäßig die Zukunft ist ja Gott sei
Dank noch weit wegit Z Abschluss habe
ich noch ein paar kurze Fragen für dich
was wolltest du den als Kind werden war
wird jetzt lustig wir haben als Kind
immer unglaublich Vulkane fasziniert und
ich w immer als Kind noch islandziieren
und vulkanologin werden das war das habe
ich mal immer als Kind so vorgenommen
war das war so cool wenn ich das machen
konnt und ja meine Mama hat es nicht so
super gefunden und dann bin ich halt
beim beim beim Kanos Sport stecken
bieben aber ja das war mein erster
Berufswunsch ein spannender berufwunsch
ist ganz interessant ja ohne Sport bin
ich
unvollkommen das habe ich jetzt schon
öfter gehört meine stärkste Eigenschaft
würde ich als folgendes bezeichnen auch
das Gute in schwierigen Zeiten zu sehen
das heiß immer der Blick auf das
Positive mein unnützes Talent ist
Tischfußball gute tischfußballerin aber
richtig gut ich kann super wutzeln
jaut
Talent ja auch auch was neues ich träume
von einer Olymp Medaille da wünschen wir
dir natürlich dafür ganz viel Erfolg
alles Gute liebe Anna danke danke das
war's von uns sportrapport danke dass
ihr wieder mit dabei wart wir sehen uns
beim nächsten Mal bis
[Musik]
dann